everyone's texted me about cash now
here's the thing got to be thinking
about people are where they are in their
lives because they listen to someone's
advice and someone giving their advice
and you take it in that situation you
have two characters one is the
influencer the other is the influenced
you listen to the influencer who
influenced you to go to whatever you
want to do for example the influencer
says cash is trash and you say you know
what cash is trash let me go take all my
cash and just put in a real estate
because that's I'm gonna be a
millionaire the influencer says you know
real estates the American Dream and you
go buy realistic cause you think it's
the American dream the influencer says
you know never study politics because
it's a waste of time so you don't study
any of that stuff and then you look at
that philosophy and you see if it works
during good and bad times and if a
philosophy only works during good times
is not a worthy philosophy to study if a
philosophy is only worthy during bad
times it's also not a good worthy
philosophy to study you need a
philosophy that's an evergreen
philosophy that can be tested in good
and bad times for example cash is trash
what is the opposite of cash is trash I
don't know a single person in America
today or in the world today that doesn't
wish to have more cash why because if
you had more cash you're not going to be
controlled by anywhere you're at your
job your boss the marketplace the
industry the three-point-two
unemployment applying for unemployment
two weeks ago six point six million this
year that's 10 million people applying
for unemployment in a month of March of
record by six six hundred fifty nine
thousand was a prior one why are they
needing this kind of search because they
don't have cash real estate is the
American Dream is real estate really the
American Dream or is it a great
marketing job because the real American
Dream is equity entrepreneurship owning
yourself something owning a piece of
something where it's not just putting
all your money into a home average real
estate return three point two percent
long-term am I really going to become
wealthy to that was that really the
right way to go maybe the American Dream
is entrepreneurship entrepreneurship
they never study politics Plato once
said those who say never study politics
will be fooled by those who do meaning
those who say it's foolish to not study
politics will be governed by fools who
do
that means if you don't study politics
other people that do study politics who
are fools will govern you and they'll
make decisions for you do you want that
to happen so maybe you are a privately
study politics maybe you don't publicize
it but you go study politics and see
what is really going on what is the
motive behind these guys would have the
most emotive behind these guys
again the whole purpose of today's
message is the following sometimes it
requires a bad time to show up for you
and I to ask ourselves if our
philosophies work during good and bad
times sometimes during bad times you and
I have to ask ourselves who are the top
five people I listen to the most how are
their philosophies doing today
when the economy expands for a hundred
and twenty nine months in America you
know how easy it is to make money very
easy but when the economy isn't and it
drops 39% in a month
now which philosophies work because cash
is king today because entrepreneurship
is King today having his skill set is
King today knowing the politics and a
motivation behind politicians came today
because you know no one can control you
so write down whoever the influencer it
is that influences you and write down
their philosophies and see if it's
worked for you good and bad times if it
has keep studying those people if it's
not you may need to make some
adjustments to which influencers you
study too as far as you know I get asked
a lot about supplements and stuff and I
saw some people are asking questions
about supplements I think at this point
you know there's reasonable evidence
that zinc is probably worth taking the
challenge of course is in what format so
zinc is not necessarily the most
bioavailable thing depending on how you
take it but you know you're generally
going to need about I don't know call it
you know thirty to fifty milligrams of a
relatively bioavailable zinc the
lozenges which are typically pretty good
have been kind of sold out on Amazon for
quite some time
so you know zinc supplementation
probably makes a little bit of sense you
know as far as anything else I think
it's just too hard to say and my concern
with it is I wouldn't want to give
somebody a false sense of confidence
that because they're taking you know
vitamin C or vitamin D which also is
probably quite important especially if
you can't get out into sunlight so you
know people who live in parts of the
country or the world where they can
still despite a quarantine get out and
get sunshine I think that's hugely
important to get vitamin D in the
natural way if people can't then I think
supplementing vitamin D would also
matter but again you just don't want
people to think that that protects them
from washing their hands and things like
that yeah and of course distancing from
you know people who themselves are not
able to quarantine so right now people
are stuck inside with their other halves
some of people are thinking like oh my
god this is amazing I get to see my
partner more others are ready to ring
each other's necks what is like the one
encompassing thing that all couples can
immediately do right now together in
order to get through this and I don't
just want to say like to survive it but
to actually use it as a way of getting
stronger together instead of like just
endure one flip your mindset this is rad
like just say it this is rad
I'm so excited even if you don't believe
it it will do something to your mind
this is rad there's an opportunity here
I know it we just have to find the
opportunity I cannot tell you how often
I use that strategy I just immediately
default to this is rad this is the best
thing that's ever happened and then I'll
go how is this the best thing like and
then I'll find like oh actually this is
really powerful actually this is this is
amazing but it just started as a
counterpunch right so world Pop's me in
the mouth my nose is bleeding I lost a
tooth and I'm like this is amazing and
that's my counter punch because now I'm
like I'm going to figure out why this is
amazing and it is startling how
effective that is you can drink it not
make dreams your master we all have
dreams I have when I was younger so I
figured the best place make those dreams
come true our isolation so I walked into
isolation as Dave the guards
they are walked out of isolation is
guidance when you become a savage is it
isolation when you train it for a bit
even a fighter or just a boxing match
you'll stay outside of isolation you go
in isolation and that's what your mind
changes that's what your focus changes
you get occasion changes don't do this
time to [ __ ] you're mine you can see
great strength gain focus isolation if
the key to strengthen your mind
come on the savage listen as this global
pandemic continues and carries on more
and more and more people are getting
trapped in that feeling of fear that
feeling of scarcity that feeling of oh
my gosh will this ever end will I
survive this and listen it is a scary
time and it is a difficult time and
during that then we must as hard it is
as hard as it is demand something more
from ourselves because it's not normal
conditions right and I know how easy
this is said yes I know it's hard and
it's normal not normal condition so I'm
just going to bow out right now but I'm
I'm gonna I'm gonna take a pause or you
know I'm gonna pause my entire life I'm
gonna bow out I'm gonna avoid this tract
quit like disappear in my comforts and
by the way I know some people are doing
that and it is create this big
controversy of ok is this you know some
battle right now between you know
personal development spirituality and
people talking about hey you should just
be coping with this and some other
people saying hey you should be moving
through with this and you're hearing
this big debate of peace vs.
productivity and those who espouse
productivity and moving ahead and
engaging this as a role model and
summoning the best of who we are
sometimes that's misconstrued as saying
don't cope don't take time you know
don't you know give yourself an
opportunity to rest or recover and
listen I'm here to tell you this is not
a binary conversation of
you rest and cope or you keep moving
ahead and that's called a false
dichotomy right y'all y'all know I'm
talking about that's a false dichotomy
it's not rest and recover and cope or be
productive focused and move ahead and
confident each day it's not an either/or
cuz real coping is understanding that
you must actively rest actively recover
and actively have a sense of purpose or
mission or things to do each day to move
your life forward even if it's small
little things and so I just want to
point that out because you know I've
never ever ever had so many people say
you know things that were just so
uninformed by either personal
development or psychology or just
general like working with other people
because listen you can be empathetic
right now with other people like many of
you you had you've got teams you've got
people you lead you got people you serve
you've got people who take care of your
family is counting on you you can
absolutely be empathetic and empowering
but what I won't be and I made this
choice it was very hard at the beginning
cuz I thought you know what if I'm still
gonna tell people not to forget their
dream if I'm still gonna tell people yes
the world is chaotic but you know what
that means
you've gotta adopt the role model
mindset because a year from now you're
either gonna be proud of how you dealt
with a difficult time in life or you
know you know what I really let myself
go or you know what I really just I quit
or you know what really I just stopped
trying and I I just I kind of hid out I
just had to kind of hit on the couch the
whole time waiting for it to pass now
I'm somebody here who is not against you
being on television observes are you
know I'm not against you sitting and
watching television even though that's
becoming like what a lot of people think
about me that is not what I'm saying at
all
if you want to you know have some
Netflix or Hulu or Disney and watch some
television at night no problem and
people say well but Brendon some people
just need a whole weekend to do that I'm
like fine but we're months
into this thing we're months into this
thing if you are on the couch for months
at a time
disengaging not doing things actively to
care for your family care for your
health care for your mission for your
team that's not healthy and let's not
pretend well they're just coping Brendan
I might Donna know I listen yes we all
have different styles of coping and I'm
the person that from day one I said
everyone's in a cup with this so
differently because I've been coaching
and training and working with people one
on one for two decades you know a lot of
armchair you know personal developing
people right now are saying oh well you
know just let people cope their way
through this and we'll all get through
and they're very enabling with poor
habits but I'm the high-performance
habits guy I care about how you're
performing for your family right now
because they're watching see if we don't
care about our performance what are we
gonna have during this pandemic we're
gonna have a greater emotional contagion
that is this association that is this
engagement that is those things up
avoidance and seeking like comfort or
simple pleasures at the cost of those
difficult actions to take those small
movements each day to keep moving like
forward because listen you can have both
you can actively recover rest and cope
because listen every single day I'm
still making sure I do my meditation I'm
still making sure I get a walk-in or a
meditation and I'm still working really
hard to get those eight hours of sleep
in which is really hard right now when
there's lots of stress I'm still making
sure I'm focusing on my breath I'm still
making sure that every 50 minutes I get
up from my desk I closed my eyes I
bounce in place I take ten deep breaths
to reset my eye strain to open up my
lungs to move the lymph around my body a
little bit get some water I'm still
making sure I talked to friends I'm
still making sure that I have time to
kinda like chill with the book
or watch a show with my lady Denise who
many of you all know so I'm still yes
actively caring for my health you can
and you must actively care for your
energy and your recovery and your coping
to be a high performer we found that in
the world's largest study of high
performers if you read high forms habits
is chapter two right they generate
energy how they generate energy by
protecting it by making sure that
they're doing things to release the
tension in their life in healthy and
productive ways if you want more advice
wisdom guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there
the most important thing people can do
for their immune system is sleep